في التنس حقق اللاعب السوري انجازا كبيرا
بعد فوزه بلقب البطوله الختاميه حين تغلب
في المباراه النهائيه على النرويج كاسبر
رود ليعادل الرقم القياسي للعب السويسري
روجر فيديرير بي سته القابنا لكل منهما
وحسم اليقوفيتش المباراه
بواقع 7 5 6 3 في مباراه استمرت لمده
33 دقيقه
الفوز ان مرور وقت طويل على اخر مره توج
فيها باللقب يجعل حصوله عليه اجمل
سامي يوسف
طويله لكن لهذا الانتصار طعم خاص لكون
انتظرت سبعه اعوام
انا في حاجه للراحه بعض الاسابيع لقد كنت
متعبا حقا وعلى وشك الانهيار طوال هذه
السنه سواء بسبب البطولات او بسبب انتظار
الاجراءات الاداريه للسفر لذلك انا سعيد
لكون انهيت الموسم بهذا الشكل
اكبر لاعب يفوز بكاس الاساتذه كما انه
ارتقى الى المركز الخامس في التصنيف
العالمي للاعبي التنس المحترفين
[موسيقى]